An advanced pay for performance system
rewards providers who are able to
provide higher quality
care at a lower cost.
There's evidence that
these programs can work.
Here are the results of the Physician
Group Practice, or PGP, demo,
a well known Medicare pilot
conducted in ten medical practices.
All of the groups achieved improvements
in 25 of 27 quality metrics for
the key diseases shown here, and you see
the percentage of improvement as well.
Four practices earned a bonus for
outstanding performance.
Marshfield Clinic earned
half of the total bonus.
And in explaining how they did it,
their CEO cited a well developed
electronic health record and
went onto describe how it reduced
unnecessary duplication of services
by making information available to all
providers caring for each patient.
In fact, Marshfield developed
the EHR system they were using,
and in April 2015,
at the largest health IT industry
meeting held each year called HIMS,
they introduced a very innovative
new version of it that combines the
traditional charting functions of an EHR
with fully integrated population health
tools to better manage chronic disease
patients like Marla when
they aren't in the office.
They also added fully integrated
analytics so that physicians could
easily understand the overall quality
of care being delivered by them to all
their patients and
a fully integrated patient portal so
that Marla could engage with
her physicians in her care.